Recently,
the first lady of South Korea grabbed public attention while accompanying
her husband president Yun sukyo in ktt g 20 Bali.
Because the first lady of South Korea looks youthful
and fashionable despite being 50 years old.
It turned out that he was also a CEO of a company and had apologized in public.
Excerpted from tribunnews dot.
Com first lady Kim Kunhee was born in South Korea's
grandparent piong regency on 02/09/1972.
In addition to being the first lady and companion to president
Kim is the CEO of the content kovana company.
The company is engaged in art exhibitions.
Kim himself was interested in the art world for that he majored in art while
studying in college until he earned a bachelor's degree with good grades.
Kim Kunhi and Yoon Sukyo got married in 2012.
Kim was 40 and Yoon was 52.
She once apologized to the public when her husband was the
presidential candidate of the popular power party when Kim
was said to have falsified aspects of his credentials.
In his resume.
Kim apologized for the controversy for exaggerating his resume.
Hope you can stay in Indonesia longer can enjoy in Bali.
I am sure you will fall in love with Indonesia Bali.
Thank you
This week s update.
Stay tuned for more latest information only on tribunnews YouTube channel.
Thank you for watching.
Don't forget to like subscribe and share.